[Music]
thank you for coming and attending this
session you've chosen the best session
it next to sit in on my name is Joe kava
I'm the vice president of global data
centers at Google what that means is
that I helped to lead the teams that are
responsible for the end-to-end lifecycle
of our data centers from the very
beginning stages of site selection and
location strategy to procuring all of
our energy contracts including our
renewable energy to design construction
and full operations of the data centers
all around the world I've been at Google
just over eleven years and I've had the
pleasure of working with amazing people
and seeing incredible technology evolve
so today I'm gonna try and give you a
little bit of a insider's view into our
data centers what makes them special
what I really appreciate about our data
centers and as a clue it has a little
something to do with sustainability you
probably saw this on their screen as you
entered the room we're using a tool
first time at at next it's called dory
it's an internal tool that we use at
Google for all of our large meetings
like this so feel free to open up the
tool onion on the app and you can submit
questions and upload other questions and
I'm gonna try and leave time here at the
end so that we can address them and
we'll also have mics open for live
questions if you'd like okay so let's
start with a little bit of an
examination of what do you need from a
data center um well if you're like me
and I suspect most of you are you you
know you need your data center to be
very high performance you need it to be
highly available you need it in places
where you need to be you needed to be
extremely reliable needs to be ultra
secure and if you can wrap that up with
a bow of sustainability then you've got
something that is
really meeting all your needs in a data
center since the earliest days of when I
got to Google and actually long before I
was there for about two decades now
Google has been the leaders in ultra
high performance computing systems one
of the things that impressed me when I
first arrived was that even as
innovative as the data centers were I
remember the very first day that I was
at a Google Data Center and everyone
kind of wonders what a day to senators
like at Google I did to when I got there
I was kind of tracing the path of the
electrons in my mind and I was just
shaking my head and and my manager asked
me is something wrong and I said no it's
just so obvious I don't know why
everyone isn't doing it but what
impressed me most is that no matter how
good we're doing we always believe we
can do better so we have a relentless
focus on innovation and constant
technology evolution so ultra high
performance what does that mean well for
us it means that we don't rely on just
off-the-shelf components we design and
build almost every part of the stack
custom built for us for ultra high
computing ultra high efficiency at the
price and end performance that we need
it to be so this is everything from our
custom designed high-voltage substations
that are on the campus of all of our
data centers to the server's themselves
the racks that the servers go in the
custom-designed cooling solutions at
those racks mate - - even the way we
operate the cooling plants I'll touch on
that a little bit more but it as I
mentioned it truly is just a relentless
focus on continual improvement and
constant innovation so as I mentioned
these are built for Google there's no
unnecessary components in our servers
they're stripped down just ultra high
performance computers this reduces
vulnerabilities as you know we have a
very very
strong focus on security so all of our
servers have our built-in Titan chip
from the time that they're manufactured
for us to our specifications and that
Titan chip is helping to secure every
server throughout its entire lifecycle
at Google all of our services are
dynamically allocated we talked a lot
about this our board system which we
have been using internally at Google
since the earliest days that eventually
became the orchestration layer for all
of our our containers and so we are
constantly provisioning and upgrading
and redoing our infrastructure in since
we're constantly upgrading and changing
it has to be very flexible and adaptable
so we put a high priority on optionality
I'll talk a little bit more what that
means has to be extremely efficient
ability to scale and our data centers
also are compliant with the Open Compute
program the racks that are available
through that so why is that important
well it just means that we're leveraging
the rest of the data center ecosystem as
well not just relying on on what we do
we also have our own teams that are
staffing the data centers in particular
our Hardware operations teams that are
there 24/7 at our data centers they are
doing all of our deployments maintenance
upgrades repairs of all of the hardware
all the servers storage and network in
the data centers they're there in real
time so they respond very quickly they
have all the tools necessary to make
their job very efficient and they are
highly reliable and do this all the time
so we're not relying on an SLA with a
service provider to come in and service
the data centers we do that ourselves
since I've been at Google we have
constantly been innovating and Cooling
why is that important well data centers
consume a lot of energy
and in a data center one of the largest
overhead components is related to the
air conditioning or the cooling of the
data center so we have innovated our
cooling systems about every 18 months
since the time that I've been at Google
we've used a variety of cooling
techniques we use sea water in Finland
we bought a paper mill turned it into a
big data center campus and it actually
was sitting right on the Gulf of Finland
so we were looking at that water that
was about 14 degrees Celsius all year
round and said we can use that so that
data center is 100% cooled by sea water
we use reclaimed and storm water in a
data center in the southeast of the
United States we built a storm water
capture and reuse system so we're
cooling the data center with storm water
there in Belgium were sited right next
to a big industrial shipping canal so we
use the industrial shipping canal water
kind of the point is you see where I'm
going with this we don't have a cookie
cutter design we don't have a
one-size-fits-all model we optimize the
designs of the data center for that
specific location for the environment
that it's working in to make most use of
the natural resources that are there
okay so that's what you need from a data
center but you also have to consider
where the data centers are you need them
in the right locations they have to kind
of meet you where you need to be so we
have a very large footprint of data
centers we have 16 global campuses when
I talk about a campus a campus to us is
typically hundreds of acres with many
buildings many data center buildings on
each campus all connected by one of the
world's largest mostly Hyatt most high
performance public networks available we
have 19 regions for our cloud compute we
have 58 availability zones there 134
points of presence we are in over 2
hundred countries around the world all
interconnected with hundreds of
thousands of miles of fiber including 13
of our own subsea cables making us
really the largest overall compute
infrastructure of any of the any of the
major players okay so even long before
cloud computing was a large business for
us we had been building this
infrastructure for a couple decades to
service our own needs to service you
know Gmail in search and ads and all of
the the you know YouTube and all of the
Google services so we have been building
this infrastructure and we learned how
to scale and we learned how to build
efficiently for our own internal needs
what that means is that we have eight
products currently that each are serving
over a billion active customers a day
it's a lot of learning that came with
that and all of that gets applied to
Google cloud so they're benefiting from
two decades of learning of how to scale
how to build how to do things hyper
efficiently so where are our data
centers well we have data centers
campuses on four continents North
America South America Asia and Europe of
course we pick the sites based on a
rigorous time-tested site selection
criteria we take input from our internal
customers cloud is one of our largest
customers now dictating a lot of where
they want to be to serve the customers
and meet you where you are so with that
we look for things that we can more or
less build into for the next decade or
so so our strategy is that we want to
find sites that we can be building at
and building up for about 10 years or
more there's a long list of criteria a
lot of people always ask me you know how
do you choose the datacenter site
and if I were to quote the head of our
site selection team he would probably
say it's more or less the art of
compromise because there is no one site
that meets a hundred percent of every
single thing we would love so we try and
find the best compromise but what that
means is that we wind up like this site
here is in Belgium we wind up with a
large parcel of land that we can build
multiple data centers on for many years
to come and that gives us access to our
customers gives us access to a workforce
gives us access to high quality fiber
and more importantly every day gives us
access to renewable energy this
particular data center is in Iowa this
is in our central region this is the
first part of the parcel that we
developed this part of the parcel is 300
acres the overall site is about three
times that size if you were to measure
this out this fits about 235 American
football fields on this part that's the
developed part we have another two
parcels that we could develop that are
equally this large you'll see in the
foreground here that that that small
building that's a one-story datacenter
that building is about a third of a mile
long and then behind it you see the data
center that's a little taller
that's a two-story data center also a
third of a mile long and then the ones
that you see that are being built behind
that those are four-story data centers
also will be about a third of a mile
long when completed the amount of
capacity here is staggering and it
provides a good exercise opportunity for
our teams that are at the site they can
just jog around the perimeter and do
about almost three miles of jogging just
to go around the buildings right now
okay so you've got the what you need you
got the where you need it
but what about how well you need it
available all the time if you caught the
keynote this morning by ORS he mentioned
that unsolicited by Google not
commissioned by us at all but an
independent industry analyst said that
by far Google Cloud has the lowest
downtime of any of the major cloud
providers that's not by accident it's
because of the way that we design build
and operate our data centers and when we
say seven by 24 by 365 we really mean
that the design principle of our data
centers is to be fault tolerant and
allow us to maintain the data centers
transparent to all of you what that
means is that you know look you can hope
that things don't break but I'm here to
tell you things break when they do break
you shouldn't care because it should be
transparent to you so that means we have
to do maintenance and we have to do
upgrades and repairs while the data
center is still alive so we build in the
ability to to one make it fault tolerant
and to make it concurrently maintainable
we also build in hooks I talked a little
bit earlier about our our value of
optionality what that means is that you
know we don't have a crystal ball I
don't know exactly what we're gonna need
from our data center a few years from
now I don't know what the latest
generation of platforms that are gonna
be developed are but we want to add in
the hooks that allow us to accommodate
for whatever our platform's development
team comes up with one example is when
we built our first data centers we
didn't know about the TPU systems that
were developed for our ml and AI
applications however we were able to
accommodate those and even the latest
generation that requires water cooling
at the chip level we were able to
accommodate that because we had built in
the hooks to allow us to do those types
of things in the future so really what
the idea there is that we're looking to
the future and were
we're planning to be able to accommodate
whatever the requirements are and from
our operations team one of our core
principles is on continuous learning
continuous improvement and what that
means is transparency if you make a
mistake you can't hide it
people make mistakes it's okay we have
kind of a no blame policy because we
just want to learn from what happened
and it's typical in the industry that of
all the data center failures still about
70 percent of all data center failures
today are related to some form of human
error at Google
ours are much less it's a little bit
over 15% that are related to some sort
of human error however because of our
designs because we don't expect
perfection we designed for them to be
tolerant of mistakes and what that means
is that even though there were 15% of
the errors that were human related none
of them resulted in downtime with the
data centers that's also quite different
from the industry average in order to
help our teams manage the data centers
we have to monitor everything you might
say that we're a little bit data
obsessed so we are monitoring every
aspect of the data centers from the
server's themselves monitoring
temperatures and air pressures and flow
rates and in the mechanical cooling yard
the the flow rates and differential
pressures of the the cooling systems on
the electrical side everything from the
high voltage substation all the way down
to the the server level is monitored and
of course security all of our security
systems all of our multi-layer security
systems so these are all monitored truly
we have world-class monitoring from chip
all the way to chiller and that enables
our teams to understand what's going on
so that they can best operate maintain
and repair the data centers okay
speaking of security data centers have
to be ultra secure and ours are ultra
secure there is a recent CBRE study that
said that still one of the highest
priorities in site selection for where
to place their their equipment in a data
center is based on the security profile
of the data center so we take that very
seriously we employ a kind of a
defense-in-depth type of a strategy for
physical security at the data centers
that means that from the very outer
perimeter you know around a campus
that's hundreds of acres large there's
already barriers in fencing to prevent
people from just wandering in and the
closer you get to the data center itself
the higher the security the more rigid
the the the policies are and what all
this means is that out of all the data
centers around the world less than 2% of
Googlers have ever set foot in one of
our data centers and that's done by
design because protecting the data and
the information and the privacy of our
users is at the foremost of our design
criteria for the data centers so unless
you have a job that requires you to be
at the data center to perform that job
you don't go to the data centers it's
just that strict so I talked about our
physical security but truly physical
security and information security have
to go hand-in-hand
it's part of the same design criteria
however our information security team
are separate from my team and that is
done by design because one they truly
are
the world's experts in in protecting
information security it's a very large
team they've been published and written
books on security principles and all
that and truly they need to be
standalone and it's also for governance
because you want the the two teams to be
little checks and balances on each other
so as I said on the physical security
side we use a multi-layered strategy to
get into the data center itself you have
to have a badge that authorizes you to
be there and that's tied to your
credentials of course then we have
biometric authentication which is pretty
typical but then we have a lot of other
layers of security that are not seen so
we know who is in the data centers where
they are we know what they've touched
why they did it what actions they took
so that we have complete end-to-end
traceability of everything that's
happening in the data centers this is a
quote from data center knowledge that
basically it's just summarizing what
I've been saying is that data center
security measures are built into pretty
much every single layer of the system
from the data center itself the building
the security principles the security
designs all the way down to the server's
themselves and our custom security chips
built into the servers okay
now we know what you want what you need
from a data center we know how you need
it where you need it so we've covered
most of the reasons but what if you
could wrap all this up with
sustainability also more and more our
customers are telling us that they have
their own corporate mandates around
sustainability and energy use and
renewable energy purchases so we have
been focused on sustainability for long
before I came to Google we were the
first company to achieve a zero carbon
footprint and I'll talk a little bit
more about that but really our
sustainability efforts are broken into
three kind of pillars if you will
energy efficiency because truly the best
use of energy is the energy you don't
use in the first place so we've been
laser focused on energy efficiency at
the data centers second our use of
renewable energy to power the data
centers I'll get into a lot more detail
about that and lastly our commitment to
a circular environment and our
philosophy of a zero waste to landfill
and I'll talk more about that as well so
as I said the best energy saved is the
energy not consumed in the first place
Google Data Centers are without a doubt
some of the most efficient in the world
what that means is that compared to a
traditional enterprise data center a
Google Data Center consumes about half
of the energy that a traditional
enterprise data center would and at the
same time we're delivering seven times
more compute power at our data centers
today than we were just five years ago
so what that means is that that's a lot
more Gmail a lot more search a lot more
YouTube cap videos and a lot bigger
cloud for the same energy footprint as
just a few years ago as a matter of fact
one measure of energy efficiency in the
data centers is a very simple metric
called PUA most of you have probably
heard of it it's a very simple ratio
it's the total energy consumed at the
data center divided by the IT energy
used and so everything else is overhead
so it's a ratio that generally measures
you know something above one and most
average data centers are still about one
point five eight what that means is they
have 58% overhead our data centers have
11 percent overhead and this is a
trailing 12-month average across the
fleet of every single one of our data
centers around the world this is not
cherry-pick this is not our best data
center this is across the entire fleet
and it's been that way
a long time but we didn't just rest on
making energy efficient data centers and
building energy efficient computing
systems we then decided to try and make
better use of the data that we're
getting from our data centers one of our
engineers came up with the idea that
said if we could build a machine
learning algorithm to analyze these
volumes of data that we're gathering
every day at the data centers maybe we
could find some insights that would help
us drive the energy efficiency even
further that's exactly what he did and
then he partnered with our deep mind
group to basically make it production
worthy we employed that and now we have
the full ML system operating parts of
our cooling systems at the data center
fully autonomously very safely and of
the energy consumption for the cooling
we've achieved about a 30% reduction in
the energy consumption for cooling by
having the ml system operate the data
center cooling system for us the way it
does that it's very simple it's looking
at about 19 to 20 independent variables
in real-time and it's matching the
cooling needs to the data center load at
that time so it's doing it in real-time
and it's constantly adjusting and this
is basically far more efficient than
humans could do it and so we developed
it we tested it over many years and
little by little we made it fully
autonomous so now it's controlling the
data center cooling as I talked about we
have a strong commitment to powering the
data centers on renewable energy so we
started our renewable energy in our zero
carbon journey roughly in about 2007
when we decided that as a company we
were going to achieve zero carbon
footprint and we did achieve that in
2007 and we did that primarily by buying
very high quality carbon offsets so we
were just offsetting our carbon
footprint
and we did that for 10 years and in 2017
we apart from celebrating the 10 year
anniversary of being carbon neutral
company we also announced that we had
achieved another major milestone and
that was that we are now buying enough
renewable energy to offset the entire
consumption of energy at Google Data
Centers and Google overall the entire
enterprise what does that mean that
means that we are the world's largest
corporate purchaser of renewable energy
we have since 2000 roughly 10 ish we
have signed over 30 large-scale Power
Purchase Agreements for solar and wind
energy that is over three and a half
gigawatts of energy under contract so we
are now matching for every kilowatt or
megawatt hour of energy we consume
around all of Google we are now buying
at least an equal amount of renewable
energy and we are the first company of
our skies to ever achieve 100% matching
of our consumption versus renewable this
is a little bit of our journey when we
started in 2007 frankly I should have
put down this slide when I was just
saying all that stuff but um anyhow like
I said we now have over three and a half
gigawatts under contract we've spent
over five billion dollars on these
energy purchase agreements in 2017 as I
mentioned we had 10 consecutive years of
carbon neutrality and we matched 100% of
our consumption but as I talked about we
don't rest on our laurels and so even
that is not good enough for us because
in order for us to truly take
responsibility for energy footprint and
our impact to the environment and the
climate we need to be able to match our
energy consumption with renewable energy
24 hours a day seven days a week
as you know some of the grids in which
we operate don't have abundant renewable
energy on them in some places the
regulatory environment doesn't allow you
to go out and purchase your own
renewable energy contracts so in order
to achieve that we're gonna have to come
up with some creative thinking so the
team's been doing that and one of the
demonstrations of this is that in Taiwan
where the regulatory environment
previously had not allowed corporate
companies to go out and buy their own
energy contracts and put it on the grid
there in Taiwan so we worked with the
Taiwan Power Company and the Taiwan
national government and over a period of
time of collaborating with them we were
able to get the Taiwan Power Act changed
that allows us to pie to buy renewable
energy contracts and put it on the grid
in Taiwan so our first one that we did
is pretty unique these are kind of fish
ponds where they the fish farm they
raise fish in these ponds right so we
have a developer that is now building
solar panels above these these fish
ponds so now we have a solar pond or
solar farm above a fish farm and that's
what we're in it's right in the same
local area as where I datacenter is so
that is helping us to green our
operations in Taiwan and and helping us
basically take more accountability for
our consumption in that local region so
this is the first of a kind in Taiwan
and by the way when we make these
agreements we don't do it just for us we
make the policy so that anyone that
wants to follow our actions can do that
also
another example in Belgium we did this
this solar farm this is about 10,000
solar panels on our data center property
normally we would do these off-site
where we could have larger installations
but in this case this was a great way to
match or offset our energy consumption
for our office areas and our facilities
not the data center itself that would be
too large however in another part in the
southeast of the United States in
Tennessee and Alabama we
worked with the Tennessee Valley
Authority to build one of the largest
ppas that has ever been done in that
region
that's 1.5 million solar panels 413
megawatts that are being built
specifically for Google that will offset
our consumption in that region for the
foreseeable future so we're gonna have
to work hard to actually make this a
reality 24 by 7 renewable energy as you
know like I said renewable energy is not
available everywhere in the world it's
not available every day or every hour of
the day the Sun doesn't shine 24 hours a
day the wind doesn't blow 24 hours a day
so we're gonna have to get very creative
with this we've developed a tool that
allows us to analyze at a data center
level the consumption of the data center
and match it to what the renewable
energy generation is our for our so that
we can see how we're doing in some data
centers in parts of the world where we
don't have a lot of access to renewable
energy it's not matched very well yet in
other parts we're over 65 percent
matching today already so we have a long
way to go but we were we think it's
important enough to dedicate a team of
resources to this initiative and it's a
long-term goal I don't know when we're
gonna achieve it it is arguably a
moonshot typical Google thinking but but
in order to really take accountability
for our footprint this is what we have
to do this is as I mentioned this
happens to be the data center in North
Carolina showing how on a day hour by
hour basis we're matching with our
renewable energy so you can see that in
some parts of the year we are 82 percent
carbon free other parts of the year
we're 49 percent carbon free so it
changes a course seasonally an
hour-by-hour but this is giving us the
insights that we need the really cool
thing that we did remember that that ml
system I told you about that was
operating our data center cooling sis
well deepmind and us partnered together
to adjust that system and said what if
we apply that same type of machine
learning to a wind farm what would that
do
well we developed jointly a new ML
system that allows us to predict what
the energy generation of a wind farm
will be 36 hours in advance why is that
really important because if you're a
grid operator the intermittency of
renewables make it really hard for you
to plan how much generation you need you
know what your demand is gonna be more
or less because you've got a long
history of looking at your your demand
from your customers but you don't know
what the output of that wind farm is
gonna be tomorrow
well this ml system allows us to predict
it with high degree of fidelity what it
is so now they can plan on that and put
that into their base load calculations
we can better utilize the full output of
the wind farm which has resulted now
that you know the early days I don't
know if this is going to be how it is
always I hope it's better but we've
already achieved about a 20 percent
improvement in the value of the wind
farm that this was done at the value of
that that renewable energy so I think
there's a lot of a lot of Hope here ok
and the third pillar is the circular
economy and our belief is that we should
reuse and recycle and have a zero waste
to landfill goal we have achieved zero
waste to landfill at some of our data
centers but not all of them today across
the entire portfolio were 91% diversion
of waste to landfill that means that we
only nine percent of all of our waste
whether it's from construction or
operations is making it to a landfill
this required us to think about things
differently to come up with better reuse
strategies so that we can take
components that maybe aren't used for
that particular customer but use them
for another internal customer like for
instance if search said those those
machines are kind of out of date for us
but
some of our other you know internal
services can still use them so rather
than just you know recycle them we're
reusing a lot of that we're
remanufacturing a lot of our servers
with with recycled components and we're
reselling some of our components as well
so that we're really diverting a lot of
that otherwise what would be electronic
waste and it's not just us talking about
it but a lot of other people have
noticed our sustainability efforts so
we've been at the top of the the CDP
awards list for many years we were given
the Zayed future energy award in Abu
Dhabi
a couple of years ago so it's being
noticed it's not just we're doing it for
ourselves but we're doing it for all of
you all of our customers as well because
now you know that the workloads that you
run in in Google cloud are helping you
achieve your own sustainability and your
own carbon neutrality initiatives so
this is a quote here from one of our
customers Etsy their CTO said that
underneath their ecological goal they
want to be a hundred percent renewable
electricity by 2020 and that they know
that all of their workloads that they're
processing with us on Google cloud are
helping them to achieve this initiative
because they are already being powered
by renewable energy on our our cloud so
if we review our core principles or core
principles for our data center program
our around performance availability
reliability security and an
environmental responsibility and a
commitment to a hundred percent
sustainability we truly are building the
world's most sustainable cloud
[Music]